hi there I'm glad to be here and I like
to tell you about some of our recent
data related projects at JetBrains let
me briefly introduce myself my name is
Vasily I work at jetbrains as a data
scientist and product manager in data
loss team jetbrains is a software vendor
we develop and sell IDs and developer
tools and since we are at the data
conference you might have heard or use
my charm and regarding data lore date
lore is our recent product for data
analysis and machine learning you can
easily create some predictive models
rich visualization and share it with
your colleagues get some code review
there everything in cloud and for free
and my product my project called AI
intentions and code completion so I'll
guess all of you have heard a lot about
AI in use and in the web and I apologize
for mention these two letters in my
topic but it's a good way to just to
indicate the idea behind this meaning to
predict something based on the user's
behavior patterns and content so and
also when you give in a talk it's like
AI when you're working on it its ml and
when you think in how to solve this
problem it's usually a linear algebra or
statistics so I hope you won't blame me
for that to capital letters and let's
get started my presentation is divided
into two parts first will be about
intentions and the second about called
completions let's start from intentions
so the idea of the project was quite
simple data lor supports intentions
which is basically a piece of code some
recommendation based on your previous
cells or lines of code and intentions
cover a variety of actions such as such
as generating code if you
load your CSV then you have intentions
to drop an a for example in pandas or it
could be some optimization suggestion
and the idea was to rank this list of
intentions and determine the top list of
intentions
based on the previous lines of code and
the goal is to create smart called code
code helper and gather some interesting
stats from the datasets for sure we
faced several challenging challenges
during this project the first one was
about privacy we can't access the users
source code and we cannot match the
exact line of code with intention which
were activated or invoking and the
second we got the statistic about our
usage like events and it's also
anonymous and it was quite a tricky to
match the the activity of users with the
intentions from this event data so for
reinforce our model we gathered six
million public Jupiter notebooks from
the web we filter the filter them out
like a Python tuned version or just MT
or maybe very old notebooks and we also
use our internal data about usage with
more than 1 million events with
timestamps and here's the example of the
simple Jupiter notebook file with some
metadata and sales structures in JSON so
before we get started to implement
something and create predictive models
we get some insights from this 6
millions notebooks there on the slide so
basically some of the notebooks like 2.6
percent don't use Python at all there
are some vital
related Julie language or some exotic
ones like f-sharp and another interest
in fact that more than 300,000 thousands
notebooks were with sensitive data such
as credentials passwords tokens which is
also quite a lot in in that data group
of six million notebooks and also few
distributions of some statistics here's
like import stats which shows that about
15% of users don't use import at all and
well the main case cover the mm figure
with less than 10 imports per notebook
and the same folder structure which was
interesting because about third of users
don't use any subfolders in the projects
regarding technical stack we use
tensorflow for training our models by
the way by the way pycharm supports the
new version often the flop floor fully
supports it and we use tensorflow
serving for production and for serving
our models and we use flasks to pre and
post-processing our data sets via an
engineer's so to implement our model of
intentions we use a tool Stendhal
services one service for processing data
and another for predictions and
regarding prediction so each action of
the user were mapped to the vector and
then we use a LS name model and map it
this feature with the probability of the
next iteration so the idea to get the
list of top top useful intentions based
on the previous actions of user so I can
show you the theme which is better
represent the idea of
the architecture so it's like the
two-way model where we we give we have
actions from the user's notebook
tokenize this data and then make
prediction using LS TM and at the final
step we add some probabilities to get
the final list with top-ranked
intentions and the next slide shows the
simple demo of our model so on the left
side it's like the old one without any
kind of ML algorithms and the new one is
our well AI intentions where you can see
the user load some CSV file with
spenders then set a target feature and
after that with with new model you get
the train and test pleat reveals over
others whereas with the old one you just
get the list of intentions so that was
the idea of the AI intentions and as a
result we get the 60% accuracy for top
one intention and 92% for top five which
is quite good take an account the fact
that it's like the five options after
you let's say upload euro CSV file the
second part is about code completion
it's also a hot topic and lots of
companies like to get rid of data
scientists or engineers with the AI
algorithms and for sure there are lots
of existing solutions for of smart
helpers and code completions at
JetBrains we already have ml completion
ranking which could you could activate
in your settings in IntelliJ IDEA and
pycharm there are many of them like you
name it for from where major vendors but
we a date law would like to create a
specific code completion model because
data law work with
some subject subset of - because it's
about data analysis and machine learning
and we have a specific machine learning
vocabulary vocabulary so but we can also
use the whole domain for pre-trained our
model and also where you work with
jupiter notebooks you have the structure
of sales and this structure and
sequences also might be used to get
additional input features so with this
project we also face some challenges
with which are large variety of
completion data and the classical
imbalance of intent intentions data
because the vast majority of our users
don't use intentions at all
unfortunately so we have unbalanced
problem and we use our sampling to solve
that concerning pipeline so we are
dealing with with the notebooks and at
the first step we just merge like the
join all the cells and filter out
markdowns some images and metadata from
the jupiter notebooks then we we use
white pair encoder for for like full
data compression and we use last and
talking with different variety to
prepare the model for predictions the
next token will some try different
models and different value of n at this
step and on the last step we just use
the top k predictions to understand the
list of probabilities for the next line
of code or next piece of code for model
architecture we use a transformer
because it's like a state of therefore
the of the art for the last two years
for especially for NLP problems but we
use only an encoder blocks
with presidential positional embeddings
in it so and the number of attention
heads and size of blocks also vary and
to implement this model we generate by
parent coding as I mentioned before and
we mapped it with like most frequent
units and then we trained our model
using the unsupervised approach where we
have few tokens and we predict the next
one and to show the result of our model
I have some simple example with our
current proof of concept as you can see
so sometimes it shows quite a good
accuracy but the idea that you type some
some string and get there and get the
output for your next function or command
so as a result we have 57% top-1
accuracy and more moreover it it's only
200 milliseconds performance so further
further improvement and further steps
because there's always space to improve
your model we plan to add into our data
set the run time and metadata as an
additional feature because it helps us
to understand the consumption of the
each line or also we can use this for
additional loss function and we can also
plan to use the main specific Python
language to create new intentions for
like the first project which I mentioned
and the idea was to find some some
patterns during the data science
workflow to create a new intentions for
data law and also plan to implement the
evaluation metric into
data low product to understand their
real performance of our feature and this
code completion will be implemented in
the coming update of the data lore so
it's also a good time to mention my
teammates Adam from Boston and Vladimir
from Moscow so we are working on this
project and project relates to machine
learning at data lore and the final
slide is about references which from
which we got the inspiration to this to
these projects and for example the
second one attention is all good all you
need is not about some personal
development or mindfulness or happiness
is just specifically about the neural
nets a transformer architecture so
that's basically it thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
all right thank you very we have lots of
time for questions any questions in the
audience thank you for for the talk and
in regards to code completion I have a
question then maybe if nobody has a
question and then I asked about a
intentions but first the code completion
so how did it how did you what's the
specific like the details are you
predicting like based on and previous
characters the next character is it a
word based like or is there some rule
based technique in there in order to
alleviate the possible problems right so
we use different number of words and
symbols to create the prediction for the
next one and we try different like
skipping window to create the prediction
for for the next line of code and we
just choose the one with the best
performance
first of all thanks for the talk and one
thing I'm a bit confused about this when
you talk talked about the class
imbalance
did you like manually tag those or how
did you get the actual target intention
ready so as I as I mentioned there were
they were I liked the problem with
unbalanced data and for that we used
like over sampling with synthesize data
of intentions walking and we label these
samples as intentions so because for for
imbalance problem you have several
approaches like under sampling and over
sampling so which is our sampling
because we gathered six million millions
public Jupiter note books also measure
them with our 1 million events of usage
of our product like the intentions
events with timestamps and this helps us
to generate the additional classes for
intentional and to get the balanced
problem between classes I was wondering
how much faster you think you can make
it in the near future miss 200
milliseconds is already pretty fast it's
still on the edge of real interactivity
right thank you for that question it's
real depends on on performance because
it still with the current model we can
make it faster but with less accuracy
and also we have other limits such as
web based product because data lower is
in cloud you don't need some some local
environment or your machine with lots of
memory so we stuck into that limits
I think the threshold of 200
milliseconds is quite good for data
science workflow because you don't need
to like to think what when when you
write the next line of code and we aim
to do this figure for for for the next
version so I joined two minutes later so
maybe you talked about in the very very
beginning but about these AI intentions
where do you get the ground truth and
the intentions where does it come from
so in date lore we have intentions like
it's just called suggestions and when
the user press this button or like
activated we collect all the data about
this events like the type of intention
and the type of code which user generate
so we got this historical data and use
it for train our model anybody else I
have one more question how did you
determine that there were three hundred
thousand notebooks with sensitive
information basically we just count them
you use on top by hand right no of
course not we use like a simple string
mask with regular expressions to get the
pattern of off passwords and like the
form of the regular all set sensitive
data right then if there are no more
questions
let's think this oh there is well how do
you split the code of those many
notebooks into blocks for suggestions
and for chaining oh well as I shown on
this slide with with the sample of
Jupiter notebook you can easily
understand the sequence of cells and you
can filter them with some conditions and
after that you can concatenate them and
split by the
say buy packages or libraries depends on
your goal right so if there are no more
questions now let's thank the speaker
again and